♪ ♪
>> Tucker: A GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THE PRESIDENT HELD ITS FIRST
NEWS CONFERENCE IN OVER A YEAR
THIS AFTERNOON, HE TOOK
QUESTIONS FOR AN HOUR AND A
21 MINUTES AND 44 SECONDS,
BECAUSE WE WERE COUNTING.
IT WAS MOSTLY ABOUT BRETT
KAVANAUGH'S SUPREME COURT
NOMINATION BUT IN CASE YOU
MISSED IT, HERE'S PART OF WHAT
HE SAID.
>> President Trump: THEY HAVE
DESTROYED A MAN'S REPUTATION AND
THEY WANT TO DESTROY IT EVEN
MORE AND I THINK PEOPLE WILL SEE
THAT IN THE MIDTERMS.
WHAT THEY'VE DONE TO THIS
FAMILY, BUT THEY'VE DONE TO
THESE BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN OF HIS
AND WHAT THEY HAVE DONE TO HIS
WIFE.
AND THEY KNOW IT IS A BIG FAT
CON JOB.
THEY GO INTO A ROOM AND I
GUARANTEE YOU THEY LAUGH LIKE
HELL.
36 YEARS, THERE IS NO CHARGE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THE HEARINGS
ARE OVER AND THE RUMORS START
COMING OUT.
THEN, YOU HAVE THIS OTHER CON
ARTIST, MICHAEL AVENATTI, COME
OUT WITH ANOTHER BEAUTY TODAY.
LOOK, THESE ARE VERY DISHONEST
PEOPLE.
THESE ARE CON ARTISTS.
THE PRESS DOESN'T KNOW IT IN THE
PRESS DOESN'T WRITE IT.
I COULD PICK ANOTHER COURT
JUSTICE, I COULD PICK ANOTHER
AND ANOTHER, SOMEONE COULD SAY
35 YEARS AGO, TEN YEARS AGO,
FIVE YEARS AGO, HE DID A
HORRIBLE THING TO ME.
THIS IS JUST A GAME THAT THEY
ARE PLAYING.
IT'S A CON GAME AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT.
>> Tucker: WE WILL CONTINUE TO
COVER THE STORY ALL NIGHT
TONIGHT AND OBVIOUSLY THROUGHOUT
THE WEEKEND AND INTO NEXT.
THERE ARE MANY STRAINS OF IT
NOW.
ONE THING WE LEARNED FOR
CERTAIN, DEMOCRATS BADLY WANT
THEY WILL DO WHATEVER THEY     I
THEY WILL DO WHATEVER THEY     T
THEY WILL DO WHATEVER THEY     K
THEY WILL DO WHATEVER THEY     S
CONTROL OF THE SUPREME COURT AND
THEY WILL DO WHATEVER THEY     .
STORMY DANIELS HAS A NEW CLIENT
TONIGHT, AND HER NAME IS JULIE
SWETNICK.
SHE ALLEGES THAT ABOUT 35 YEARS
AGO, BRETT KAVANAUGH WAS PART OF
A GROUP OF TEENAGE BOYS IN THE
WASHINGTON, D.C., AREA WHO
COMMITTED A SERIES OF GANG.
KAVANAUGH HIMSELF SEEM TO BE
OLDER TODAY WHEN HE WAS ASKED
ABOUT THE CLAIM.
HE DESCRIBED IT AS BEING PART OF
AN EMPHASIS, EPISODE OF THE
TWILIGHT ZONE.
IN THE COMING DAYS WE WILL HAVE
TIME TO CAREFULLY ASSESS ALL OF
THESE CLAIMS AND THE MANY
COUNTERCLAIMS IN THE STORY AND
WE WILL BRING ALL OF THAT TO YO
YOU.
BUT TONIGHT WE WILL ASK YOU
QUESTIONS AND SEVERAL COME TO
MIND.
HERE'S THE MOST OBVIOUS ONE.
WHAT EXACTLY IS THEM ALLOCATION
HERE IN THIS NEW CLAIM?
RICHARD BLUMENTHAL DID NOT
HESITATE TO GIVE HIS ASSESSMENT
OF WHAT IT IS.
>> WHAT WE HAVE NOW FOR THE
FIRST TIME AS A SWORN AFFIDAVIT
THAT SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIES
BRETT KAVANAUGH AS SEEMINGLY
RATING A WOMAN WHO HAS BEEN
DRUGGED.
>> Tucker: SEEMINGLY SAID
SENATOR BLUMENTHAL.
SHE CLAIMS SOMEONE ELSE HER, AND
SO WHO EXACTLY IS THIS PERSON.
NONE OF THAT IS CLEAR FROM HER
ACCOUNT WHICH IS DOES MORE
SUGGESTING THAN IT DOES STATING.
SHE DOES CLAIM THAT SHE HERSELF
WAS BY A NUMBER OF BOYS.
WAS IT CAVANAUGH AMONG, AMONG
THEM?
WE DON'T KNOW.
WHICH ITSELF RAISES ANOTHER
QUESTION, WHY DOESN'T HER
STATEMENT SPELL OUT CLEARLY WHAT
SHE CLAIMS KAVANAUGH DEAD.
WHAT IS CLEAR IS THAT A
ACCORDING TO JULIE SWETNICK,
HORRIBLE THINGS HAPPENED IN A
SERIES OF PARTIES IN SUBURBAN
MARYLAND IN THE 1980s.
NOT TALKING DRUNKEN NAUGHTINESS,
THESE ARE WAR LEVEL CLIENT
CRIMES.
GROUPS OF YOUNG WOMEN DRUGGED
AND GANG, IT'S HORRIFYING.
SO WHY HASN'T ANYONE TAKEN US TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT?
DID HE CONTACT A MARYLAND POLICE
FIRST, THEY ARE THE ONES WITH
JURISDICTION HERE.
IS IT THE FIRST TIME THEY'VE
SEEN THESE ALLEGATIONS?
AND IF IT IS THE FIRST TIME, HOW
CAN THAT BE?
SHE DESCRIBES ATTENDING AT LEAST
TEN PARTIES IN WHICH PUBLIC
DRUGGING AND BE SEVEN TOOK
PLACE.
DID ANY OF THE MANY PEOPLE AT
THESE RATE SCENES MENTIONED
THESE CRIMES TO POLICE, THEN OR
IN YEARS SENSE?
WASHINGTON IS A VERY SMALL
PLACE.
AMONG THE PERMANENT POPULATION
HERE, EVERYONE KNOWS EVERYONE OR
KNOW SOMEONE WHO DOES.
SO WHERE ARE ALL THE WITNESSES
TO THIS?
WHERE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
SPOKEN TO WITNESSES ABOUT IT
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS?
DID SHE OR HERSELF TELL ANYONE
OVER THAT TIME?
BETH WILKINSON RAISED THESE
QUESTIONS TODAY.
>> I HAVE HAD PEOPLE CALL ME AND
EMAIL ME SAYING THEY KNOW HIM,
THEY WERE AT THE PARTIES,
THEY'VE NEVER MET HER AND NEVER
SEEN HER.
IF THIS WAS HAPPENING OVER TWO
YEARS WITH ALL THESE WOMEN AND
ALL THESE MEN, SOMEONE ELSE
WOULD HAVE HEARD ABOUT IT AND
WOULD HAVE REPORTED IT BY NOW.
>> Tucker: AFFAIR QUESTIONS.
WHAT'S THE ANSWER?
AND BY THE WAY, WHAT WAS JULIE
SWETNICK DOING AT THESE PARTIES?
SHE GRADUATED IN 1980 WHICH
MEANT SHE WOULD BE IN COLLEGE
WHEN THE PARTY TOOK PLACE AND
YET SHE WENT PARTIES TO
HIGH SCHOOL KIDS.
AT THESE PARTIES SHE SAW
HORRIFIC RAPES, AND SHE NEVER
REPORTED THEM TO POLICE.
MOST BAFFLING OF ALL, HOW DID
THE FBI MISSED THE FACT THAT
KAVANAUGH WAS PART OF A HUGE
RING?
HE'S HAD SIX FEDERAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS AND STAFF SECRETARY, HE
HAD THE HIGHEST POSSIBLE
SECURITY CLEARANCE, ONE THAT
ALLOWED HIM ACCESS TO THIS
COUNTRY'S NUCLEAR CODES.
FBI AGENTS WOULD HAVE SPOKEN TO
HUGE VARIETY OF PEOPLE WHO KNEW
OR KNEW OF AND KAVANAUGH DURING
HIS HIGH SCHOOL YEARS AND YET
NOT ONE OF THEM MENTIONED HE WAS
A SERIAL WHO COMMITTED HIS IN
ROOMS OF CLASSMATES.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
AND IF IT DID HAPPEN WE KNOW
THAT FBI INVESTIGATORS ARE
CRIMINALLY INCOMPETENT.
SO INCOMPETENT THEY MISS A
GLARING FACT LIKE THAT.
SO WHY WOULD THEY WANT TO
REINVEST KAVANAUGH SEVENTH TIME?
MANY PEOPLE WONDER ABOUT ALL
THIS, BUT NOT THE MEDIA.
HOW DARE THEY ASK, THEY SOLD,
QUESTIONS ARE FORBIDDEN HERE.
>> WHEN YOU HEAR LINDSEY GRAHAM,
A SITTING SENATOR SAY THINGS
LIKE I FIND IT CURIOUS THAT
THESE CHARGES WERE NOT BROUGHT
FORWARD UNTIL 2018, COME ON.
>> AND IT'S MORE THAN THAT HE
SAID, I HOPE PEOPLE WILL BE
HIGHLY SUSPICIOUS OF THE
ALLEGATION BECAUSE WHY WOULD SHE
GO TO TEN PARTIES, WHY WOULD SHE
CONTINUE TO HANG AROUND PEOPLE
LIKE THIS?
IF YOU TALK TO PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD OF THE PEOPLE THAT
ADVOCATE FOR VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT, THEY CALL THIS
VICTIM BLAMING.
>> Tucker: THEY CALL IT VICTIM
BLAMING, BUT IT DEPENDS ON WHO
YOU THINK THE VICTIM IS.
DUMB PEOPLE ON TELEVISION HAVE
ALREADY MADE UP THEIR MINDS
ABOUT THAT AND THEY WOULD LIKE
YOU TO SHUT UP.
BUT THERE'S NO REASON YOU
SHOULD, OR AN AMERICAN CITIZEN
AND IT'S YOUR COUNTRY.
IT'S YOUR SUPREME COURT AND YOUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IT DOESN'T BELONG TO CABLE NEWS
ANCHORS OR CREEPY LAWYERS OR
U.S. SENATORS WHO HAVE DECIDED
TO GIVE UP ON DUE PROCESS AND
INSTEAD WOULD LIKE TO ROBE
ACCUSATION AND SCREAMING.